So a Texas man was arrested with a rifle, as
well as 118 rounds of ammunition at Kamala
Harris residence the night before last. A CNN
reporter, Jim Sciutto, tweeting on Wednesday night
around 9:00 p.m. Eastern that, quote, A Texas man
arrested outside VP Kamala Harris, his official
residence at the U.S. Naval Observatory Wednesday,
was in possession of an AR 15 semiautomatic rifle.
One hundred and thirteen rounds of unregistered
ammunition and five 30 round magazines,
according to a Washington, D.C. police reports.
CNN going on to say that the individual is facing
multiple charges for the weapons as well as the
ammunition. Spokesperson for the D.C. police said
that officers went over about quarter past noon
on Wednesday because of a suspicious person based
on a bulletin that actually originated from Texas.
This individual traveling from Texas, detained by
U.S. Secret Service. There had been a region wide
intelligence bulletin about this individual. He is
a 31 year old man from San Antonio. The rifle,
the ammunition were recovered from his vehicle.
It's unclear at this time what his intentions
were, but many charges carrying a dangerous
weapon, carrying a rifle or shotgun outside of a
business, possession of unregistered ammunition,
possession of a large capacity ammunition feeding
device. And the individual was detained by,
I guess, what
you would call local police before Secret
Service showed up. We're still learning more about
what exactly his motives were. We don't yet know,
but I think many of us can sort of imagine. And
whenever this happens, you know, this is I don't
want to joke about this because what happened,
this is serious. And what happened in Georgia
with the massage parlor shooting is also serious
and insanely tragic with eight people dead.
But I started saying, you know, are we going
to hear this guy was also just having a bad day
as per the day before yesterday's press
conference with Jay Baker, the spokesman
for the Cherokee County Police, was this guy just
looking to improve the country? As we heard from
Republican Senator Ron Johnson recently about the
January 6th rioters will the gun people say the
one hundred and eighteen rounds, including the
unregistered ones, those are just for hunting
as many gun rights people say you should be
allowed to have. What is the explanation going
to be on this one from different people? And,
of course, good thing that this guy was caught,
but certainly not something that is boding
particularly well at this time. You think
when Barack Obama became president,
the number
of death threats against the sitting president,
when that stopped being George W. Bush and started
being Barack Obama went way up and under the
Trump presidency, death threats against the
president again, that rise to the level where
the Secret Service gets involved and they're
considered serious, went down. And, of course,
there are people who are going to say that,
that this is likely about race. There's no way to
know that this individual incident is we you know,
you can look at broader data, this particular
incident, we don't know. But my concern is,
given all of the concerns over the last two
months since the January riots about the role
of both military, former and current, as
well as law enforcement within the rioters,
I
just want to make sure
that the right people are in the positions
to be preventing exactly this type of guy
from being able to do harm to Kamala Harris or
whoever it is that they do want to do harm to.
We will see as we learn more what the explanation
was. Why did he travel from Texas to D.C. with the
with the rifle, with one hundred and eighteen
rounds? At this point, we just don't know.